paul let's uh
let's throw the floor to you what is
your blanket rule when it comes to
managing money in an ltr
my boss is looking to roll his guitar
there my blanket roll three thousand
dollar guitar out of my
damn i was gonna look it up online just
kidding all right so
yeah my blanket rule is that i take
charge of it right away
and i set the standards in the beginning
so i think that
what happens who got a lot of background
noise i don't know who that is in the
background there
but um i think uh what guys are afraid
to do is they're afraid to have that
discussion
or set that standard as things move
along
into an ltr it's like there's that
innate drive to want to take care of the
baby maker
and so they're afraid that if they don't
sort of
i don't know heed to her wishes and her
desires to
see all the finances and know what's
going on and
whatever and to let her have full
control over that then they
they feel like it's going to create this
conflict in the relationship they might
lose her
this that the other and it's a weak
position right and guys
lose the that battle they lose their
frame because they don't set it in the
first place
so i always recommend what i do is i
always have my exit strategy for any
relationship
laid out beforehand all right so i'm not
a big advocate of marriage
uh this day and age for a number of
reasons that you know pretty much
everyone this panel is not really a
big advocate for it but i mean think of
a marriage what do you need
a prenuptial a separation agreement i
don't care how much money you have
right um if you're cohabitating you have
to have
some kind of separation agreement
especially if you're coming
getting close to that um point in time
where you're going to be considered
common law
you know what i mean you have to lead
lead the charge
and doing these things and setting these
standards now
guys will ask me but how do you sell
that you know what i mean how do you get
her on board or whatever and
you know you can just just tell her and
that's it if you have early frame
announcement then
it's not going to be an issue you're not
going to have to answer these questions
later because you didn't address
it in the beginning but the uh the
second part is it's pretty simple
you know if you a a relationship's gonna
be healthy and ltr is healthy
if both people are there voluntarily
right
if nobody feels like they're a prisoner
or that they're trapped in the
relationship
they're making the decision every single
day to be in that relationship
then that's going to be a healthy
relationship it causes these
the conditions for both partners to
always put in that effort
right and this is how you you know spell
this out to your chick when you um
have these discussions look we're gonna
we're gonna set these standards
beforehand
for separation so that you know you
don't you never feel trapped i never
feel trapped we're choosing to be with
each other every day
because what happens is to guys i get in
like consultations who make
three four hundred thousand dollars a
year they got a couple houses
and things are going terrible with the
wife and
she controls the finances and he's
trying to get control back
yet he makes all the money and he's
scared about divorcing
because he doesn't know what that
divorce looks like he hasn't talked to a
divorce attorney
there's no prenuptial he doesn't he's
scared about well
am i going to be able to see my kids is
she going to drain the accounts is this
going to happen is that going to happen
he literally has no power no control no
frame
because he didn't set those standards up
in the beginning right
and so i'm talking about separation
because the two things go hand in hand
all right having that separation
agreement involves what you're doing
with the money what you're doing with
the finances
and basically early frame is you
say here's how it's going to be here's
the standards
and you figure it out but you don't have
to in in setting that frame you don't
have to tell her about
how much you make share what's in the
accounts
all those things you don't have to do
that i recommend that you're not giving
her all that power
to handle your finances where you're not
doing anything i made that mistake
before too
guys i've been married before i was
living out of a rucksack sending money
home
come home and she was working too i come
home to
no money in the savings account right
and a
huge uh amount of craft uh
etsy and craft stuff in the basement
we could have opened up a damn craft
store all right
and all this crap that she had wanted
and i didn't have any money in the bank
accounts and that's what
happened so you sent all of your money
back home for for her to manage when
you're out on
deployment yep yeah i was an idiot you
know i was a total idiot i just
i guess you'll never do that again right
nope
nope i just didn't worry about it i just
didn't care i was like uh you know
i'm living out of this bag and focusing
on my mission as long as i had enough
money to buy the minimal gear and
bs i need i needed to get which is very
low
you know cost really in the large scheme
of things i was just sending it back it
wasn't checking on anything wasn't
you know she would occasionally update
me on stuff and i just i had all this
you know see i was i had the framework
of well i just trust her it's fine
whatever
you know what i mean and it's not about
trust though it's about leadership
it's not like she tried to screw me over
it's that i didn't execute leadership in
that relationship like an idiot
and so money went in places they
shouldn't have gone
you know what i mean and so that's the
thing as i get these guys going well
i trust her though so good you should
trust her you shouldn't be an ltr if you
don't trust her
it's not about trust though it's about
leadership
women need to be led in the
relationships and so if you're not
executing leadership
she is going to do a bunch of things and
you're not going to be happy with those
things
if i might add an addendum to what paul
said um and this is a big risk that
every man faces because i know
we're painted as the evil bad guys in
all this a lot of you will slip into it
because you're a good guy and you want
to make your wife or your girlfriend
happy
you're like oh yeah i want to help life
well not not even that like
i think it's like i like this girl i
wonder so don't
don't give her money don't buy her a car
but get her flowers every once in a
while i don't know if you knew this
flowers are a lot cheaper than a car
get her the occasional bit of jewelry
you know take her out for dinner but for
god
don't give her the deed to the house
don't give her your bank accounts
and don't help her with rent because
you're you're then uh
enabling behaviors where she's never
going to learn so
i think you know paul poor guy out there
it might have been preoccupied with
other things than finances back home i
don't know if he was busy
or something sipping my ties in iraq
uh but he probably yeah oh here you go
take care about it but no you cannot
just give women money
so you know buying nice little trinkets
or gifts not never never above 25 bucks
though
you